[Music]
the pride of duke university daniel
jones he is the giants quarterback after
the big win against the new orleans
saints over the weekend did you watch
monday night football daniel
i watched a little bit of it uh weather
delay pushed through it past my bedtime
but i watched the first half but do you
watch as a quarterback or a fan
a little bit of both you can't you can't
see everything on the tv copy so you
gotta
kind of piece it together in terms of
what's being run and what they're trying
to do on offense and defense but it's uh
you know just fun to watch those games
but you compare yourself
like you're watching justin herbert or
watching derek carr
do you sample from anybody like i'm just
curious what what you could take from
those games or those quarterbacks
yeah i think there's certainly things
you can you can watch and pick up and uh
you know throws they're making
uh concepts are running you know how
they're how they're kind of playing the
game but um i think you also need to be
careful with that because you don't know
exactly
what they're trying to do you don't know
what their ideas are going in the game
and uh you know comparing yourself too
closely without knowing everything could
be uh misleading when's the last time
you're on the sidelines you're watching
a quarterback play and you're going oh
my god
like i don't think i can do that
i don't know i mean i think every week
you see guys who
um you know make make some plays that
that uh
impressive everyone you know everyone in
this league's got a quarterback who can
do it oh there's got to be one where you
go oh my god did you see what mahomes
did or aaron rodgers did
right yeah i think all those guys yeah
you know i mean those guys i think
herbert's one of them cars one of them
um so that was a fun game to watch last
night so
um yeah certainly you know have a ton of
respect for those guys
how much have you watched the cowboys
since that's uh next week's opponent
uh a good bit kind of getting into that
uh you know last night and then today uh
starting our prep on them so um they're
good defense ton of talent uh all three
levels of their defense and have made a
ton of plays of course a bunch of
turnovers and
you know do a lot of good stuff so
we'll have to be ready
what's it like being the giants
quarterback when you're not on the
football field how like you're walking
around but what do people say when they
come up to
you um
most of the time just just hello and how
you doing hopefully
uh you know congrats on the win when we
win and uh
just kind of say hello when we don't but
uh
you know it's uh it's good it's been
spent most of my time uh here you know
we're busy uh during the season so not a
ton of time to be out
do we like danny dimes
uh
initially initially i didn't at first uh
it's kind of corny but uh you know it's
uh
you know there's definitely worse things
you'd be called what was your nickname
growing up
i didn't really have a nickname uh
growing up
most people call me dj or
daniel but i didn't didn't have a
nickname
how good a basketball coach was jay
billis
very good he was a very good coach uh i
played with his son anthony uh
on every basketball team you know i ever
played on from probably the time i was
in third grade and uh
jay finally coached us when we got up to
aau in high school and uh i'd say we had
the
schematic advantage and the coaching
advantage in just about every game we
played did you want to play basketball
in college
i did i think uh you know particularly
growing up and through middle school
it's probably what i played the most of
it's the easiest to play you just need
you know a couple buddies and you can
you can play basketball so we were
always always playing hoops and
you know my younger brother
is playing college basketball now um so
we were always playing basketball and i
played a lot of football too but i'd say
basketball basketball is probably my
first
passion but you were there at duke when
zion was there do you think you could
have walked on at duke and played
basketball with zion
i don't know i think walking on and then
playing with zion
[Laughter]
i certainly enjoy washington
uh how close were you to going to
princeton instead of duke
uh i was i was close i think um you know
going into my senior year
uh i was committed there and uh looking
forward to that opportunity and then
um you know through that through that
senior football season uh duke came on
and being a charlotte kid being close to
duke and opportunity to play for for
coach cutt um were all things that i
couldn't pass up
are you a sh are you a carolina panther
fan
i was growing up yeah
not anymore
no not not anymore
favorite quarterback growing up was who
uh well i was a big jake talon fan
because i was a panthers fan and they
had some some great years i loved
watching him and
steve smith lucy mohammed all those guys
um but uh you know i think all the big
quarterbacks uh you know peyton and eli
obviously were huge and
you know rogers and all those guys
growing up
well congrats on the win against the
saints and good luck against the cowboys
daniel
awesome thanks so much that's uh daniel
jones and he's okay with danny dimes